flow moja LED contact POI from flow toys
and Lantern Smith I've had them for
quite a while but lately they've been
growing on me and I want to share with
you why
[Music]
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of boy spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I want to gush just a little
bit about a set of poi that have really
snuck up on me in terms of how much I
enjoy using them but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-business friend of the channel Becca
becklenen thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so I have an hour to spend in my
local dance studio this afternoon which
I absolutely adore because between the
Marley floor and the well-adjusted
temperature inside it allows me to be
able to stretch out and do things that I
normally wouldn't be able to do I
usually bring a few sets of poi with me
to the studio but in particular I've
been finding lately that my flomoages
have earned a really regular place in my
bag and in thinking about why that was I
realized that the flow mojis bring a lot
to the table that I wasn't expecting to
appreciate so as I walk down to the
studio I figured I would share with you
what these reasons are and why they are
so important to me so reason number one
has to do with why I shifted over from
using FPC pod POI to using the flow Mojo
port in the first place and that is
programmability you see earlier in the
year I was working on choreographing a
POI dance piece and as I was finishing
the final touches on it I ran across a
video about impact gloving and realized
that the flowtoys app The flowtoys
Connect app that is would allow allow me
to actually custom program a show that
would go with that dance performance and
I was just hooked by this idea and I
have to say I'm really happy with how
these elements flow together pun
intended and I'm definitely going to
look for more opportunities in the
future by which I can go ahead and
program custom mode sets for different
songs and dance performances I have to
admit this has really opened up a lot of
possibilities and I'm excited to see
where they could go in the future and
I'll go ahead and leave a link to the
video of the dance performance that I
posted back in August of this piece also
there is a video on the way explaining
how exactly I programmed the POI and
specifically kind of what theory I use
for putting together the different modes
for it so be on the lookout because that
is going to drop in the nearest Future
and of course those programs don't work
without the second thing that I've been
finding I'm really enjoying about these
and that is the modes so I think it's
fair to say at this point that I'm
somewhat legendary for my skepticism
around Advanced modes on poi
it's not that I'm against having a bunch
of modes it's that it makes it really
really difficult to navigate through or
program them there's definitely
something to be said for all the
built-in modes that we have with the
capsules among them modes that are
responsive to our movements using
accelerometer data as well as modes that
have just really cool strobe effects
that I don't think I would have noticed
otherwise and I do have to say I have
one mode in particular that is a special
favorite and that is a rainbow fade mode
that somehow utilizes a little trick of
the light in order to create pinpoints
of white light at different points
within it I never picked up on this when
I was just using the FPC pod POI but
there's something about having the
contact POI head that really makes this
mode pop and Beyond both programmability
as well as the variety of different
modes the third thing that these POI
have going for them is definitely the
brightness simply put the brighter the
POI get the more options I have in terms
of ambient lighting I can have well-lit
scenes where I'm forming as well as
perform a little bit earlier in the
evening if I'm going out and shooting
flow videos it's really really helpful
to have that kind of flexibility in
terms of what I can do for shooting so I
really appreciate it and I will say that
this is an especially great trait to
have in the dance studio where I kind of
like having the lights a little dim
knowing that the POI are going to stand
out no matter what the lighting
conditions are
it's uh it's it's pretty clutch I gotta
say next up something that I consider a
feature even though I think many of the
POI world would consider it a bug and
that is number four the weight of the
flo Mojo point so it's definitely become
fashionable in recent years for POI to
become longer and heavier and to a
certain extent I get it like uh this
tends to make the Poise performance a
lot more reliable when it comes to doing
tosses and contact work but at the same
time it also makes them less responsive
to quick and rapid changes of movements
especially as I've been exploring more
POI dance in the past few years I've
been finding that lighter POI are
actually way more responsive to those
quick movements and I find that to now
be something that I kind of treasure in
a set of poi one of those things that
has really jumped out to me lately in
terms of the contrast between POI dance
and types of dance that are really
popular on Tick Tock or Instagram is
that a lot of more traditional dancers
are just able to move far more rapidly
and make their Corey photography just
pop in ways that we can't because with
how heavy the POI are we just seem to be
moving in slow motion the entire time I
appreciate that because of the lighter
weight that these have I'm able to get
just a little bit closer to that style
of dance and I think that is really
essential to making it accessible so you
may be noticing that a lot of the
factors that I have listed thus far
don't have that much specifically to do
with the flow emojis and could work just
as well with the Pod POI 2.0 with the
FPC tethers so then why specifically the
flow mojis well there's a bunch of
reasons so as mentioned before I think
that just the spherical heads make some
of the modes pop a lot better than they
would have otherwise but that's not the
reason that I swapped out the heads in
all honesty why I swapped out the heads
for that performance was that I needed
something with the programmability of
the capsules but the last thing I
choreographed into the performance was a
contact roll so I was kind of stuck with
having to use that form factor which
really isn't the worst thing in the
world overall but I've come to
appreciate more and more having that
form factor at the end of the POI if
nothing else as I've been doing a lot
more suspensions using shotguns and
specifically putting together what I
refer to as the ice cream cone because I
just love the tactile feel of having the
spherical head just sitting on top of my
hand like this every time I wrap the POI
up
there's just something that's really
satisfying about this form factor
um you know I I love the old pod POI
shells but at the same time this just
feels right in so many different ways
which as many of you will know uh the
heads here that is these spheres are
actually made by Lantern Smith these are
their emoji heads with the flowtoys
capsules inside of them and fun fact way
back in the day when lantern Smith was
kind of putting together the initial
stages of creating these heads they did
come to me and they asked me what size
they should make them and me being a 90
millimeter purist at the time I insisted
that 90 millimeters was the right size
and of course many people have noted
that they feel like that kind of that
that little kind of nubbin on the bottom
of it makes them feel kind of strange
and believe you me if I could go back in
time and slap myself silly and tell
Charlie in the lantern Smith crew to
instead make 95 millimeter heads I would
do that in a heartbeat but truth be told
I still like the 90 millimeter heads I
don't mind a little nub it on the bottom
but I know that it's not everybody's cup
of tea
and more than anything else I just wish
I could have gotten more sales for them
that way so here I am at the studio I
hope you have enjoyed listening to me
gush about these POI and why they've
become so essential to me if I were to
change one thing if I could make one
change to these flow toys whenever you
come out with knobs that are going to
have LEDs in them I'm going to be on
board for that in a heartbeat please
make that happen sooner ran later
[Music]
thank you
do you own sets of flomo japoi from
flowtoys what is been your experience
with them leave me a comment and let me
know hey friends Drex from the future
here and somehow and all of that gushing
I managed to forget to share the fact
that I have a promo code through flow
toys so if you'd like to go grab a set
of the flomojapoi that I have been
gushing about in this video you can do
so and get a discount on your order by
using the code drexfactor 9 2023 at
checkout that is DirectX Factor 9 2023
that code will work for the rest of
September so yeah go check them out
because they're pretty lovely did you
get anything out of this video please
make sure to like comment share and
subscribe to help other people find it
and to help my channel grow
[Music]
thank you
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these awesome
people right here these are my float
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
how to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
support and if you out there watching
are not currently supporter but you'd
like to become one you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring voice spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you cool an
empty Studio I'm so here for this uh if
you'd like to check out some of my other
videos that are POI product reviews I'll
include a link to a playlist of those
down in the description as well as up on
screen if you're watching on YouTube
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow yourself today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon
peace